[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions i got nothing here
okay live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions broadcasting from the
dollar car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice in studio
today
some guys that have become good friends
because we are
brothers from another mother for sure
the minimalists are with me uh
brand new new york times best-selling
book
love people use things joshua fields
milburn and ryan nicodemus are with us
hey guys how are you
great thanks for having us congrats a
bestseller man
is everything you two touch turn to gold
for a couple of for a couple of
minimalists you generally go big yeah
i mean it's a great accolade but you
know obviously that's the way we do the
work but it's
you know we'll take it we'll take the
accolades hey i like you know it's okay
to score a touchdown the super bowl
yeah there's nothing wrong with that 100
so well done guys and i love the title
we talked about it last time you were
here i knew it was coming and
uh it's uh titling a book is tough we do
it a lot around here
amen and you can really put a crummy
title on a book fairly easily and this
this one's not it's an absolute home run
because it just tells you immediately
what's going on inside this book and
what's going on inside girl's heart
love people use things to which anyone
no matter how big a jerk they are
would say yes yeah unfortunately that's
the problem though right we
have been loving things and using people
we even have like a language problem in
a way right like i could say i love my
wife but i also
love burritos right
i love my daughter but but i i also
love my pickup truck and i think we get
a bit confused up in canada
the none of it region they have a
dialect up there they have 53 different
words
to describe snow we have one word to
describe
love and so we get really confused we
get really caught up we think the things
are going to bring us
purpose and joy and happiness and ryan
and i as minimalists we're not against
things
consumption is not a problem the problem
is consumerism
compulsory consumption buying a bunch of
things because we think that's what's
going to make us happy of course
anyone who's tried it finds that it is
a dead-end path eventually yeah we tell
folks all the time
the old the old thing from the 80s was
you know uh he with the most toys when
he dies is dead
amen yeah and it's okay to have some
toys but if your toys have you
and that's what consumerism and
materialism stuff itis i call it leeds2
your toys end up having you because you
you need this thing to be happy
i need to go on this trip to be happy
i'll be happy when
and if you fill in the blank with stuff
on that line
you're gonna be having it's gonna be a
long road yeah i mean it's an easy road
to go down i mean we see about 5000
advertisements a day so it's over a
million a year
so a lot of that you know seeps in our
subconscious and
makes us want things that we didn't even
realize we needed right because
these companies are presenting this
problem and they're like and guess what
we have the solution if you buy this one
product
yeah and it almost seems like a shortcut
right the trip of the house the car it
seems like a shortcut to
fulfillment and what josh and i did with
this book is we really went out of our
way to to kind of show people the real
work like what work it does take to feel
fulfilled we wanted to write uh kind of
a traditional relationship book
but when we were we started digging into
it we were like wait a minute there are
so many different relationships we have
in our lives it's not just with people
we write about
you know relationships with people in
there but we also write about
relationships with our money
our relationship with ourself the
relationship with our truth with uh
creativity and uh seven relationships in
total but
i think uh what i what i like most about
this book is you can read it and just
pass through it but there's actually
some real life actions you can take in
there to
to live a meaningful life so for those
those that are uninitiated which means
they're probably living in a cave
talk about what minimalism is sure and
give
give us the thumbnail background on this
that's really the first relationship in
the book is is our relationship with
stuff and because we're the minimalist
it makes sense
really our material possessions are a
physical manifestation of what's going
on inside us so if we have a lot of
clutter in our lives and our homes and
our cars and our offices
it's probably because we have a lot of
emotional clutter
mental clutter psychological clutter
spiritual clutter relationship clutter
career clutter that's all this other
clutter
and it manifests outwardly through our
things and so we clutter our lives in a
bunch of different ways
as a minimalist everything i own serves
a purpose or brings me joy
and everything else is out of the way i
think if you came to my house right now
you probably wouldn't walk in and say oh
my god this guy
and his family or a bunch of minimalists
they don't own anything you just walk in
and say wow
they're pretty tidy and that's where
minimalism starts it starts with the
stuff
but getting rid of the things is also
isn't what makes us happy that's often a
common misconception people think that
well you know i tried to buy all these
things
it didn't make me happy in fact it made
me miserable it made me overwhelmed let
me stress it put me in a ton of debt
as a result right and instead of just
getting rid of the stuff
and thinking that's going to make you
happy no letting go creates the room
to focus on what's truly important in
life which turns out
aren't things at all joshua fields
melbourne and ryan nicodemus the
minimalists are my guests this half hour
thank you for joining us america open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five the new uh
new york times bestselling book love
people use things
because the opposite never works
i love what you said about language a
while ago when you're talking about we
we misuse the word love and where i've
run into it too and working with people
on the money side is
uh everyone says i need
i need i and really we don't have really
many needs in north america that's right
we have a few we have a whole lot of
wants but we call them needs
yeah yeah i needed a new car
yes no you wanted an upgrade amen and
there's nothing evil about upgrading the
car no
that's not in and of itself right but
when you're using that language it's a
heart reflector rather than a wallet
reflector
that's spot-on in fact in the book we
have these 16 rules for living with less
to help people sort of set up some
boundaries for themselves one of those
rules is called the no junk rule
and it basically goes like this well you
know the average american house has 300
000 items in it we talked about that
last time we were on your show
and that'd be fine if all those things
are making us happier more joyous more
free
but it's often doing the opposite so the
no junk rule says everything you own
can fit into one of three piles it's
either essential
and that's what we mean we say i really
need something clothing
food shelter we all have essentials in
our lives in fact that word's been
coming up a lot over the last year
what's an essential worker
essential business essential travel it's
a little bit a little bit
insulting that some of us weren't
declared essential right
and unfortunately we've gotten confused
in our homes and saying everything's
essential well if everything's essential
then nothing is amen and so we have two
other categories we have non-essentials
those are the things that we actually
get value from i don't truly need a
couch at home i guess i could get by
without one
but i'm a minimalist not a
deprivationist and so
there's the line and so i want to have
things that truly serve a purpose in my
life so i'm not going to deprive myself
of a couch or a kitchen table or a bed
those things are great the problem is
most of the things we own 90 plus
percent
fit into that third category it's junk
we own a lot of junk and it masquerades
as though
it is valuable as though it's important
as though it's precious even though
it's junk yeah watch your language it
reveals your heart
yeah need you were forced to
you love a burrito
all of it the book is love people use
things we'll be back with more of this
discussion
right here on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
joshua fields milburn and ryan nicodemus
the minimalists
hanging out with us again today for a
couple segments brand new book
national bestseller of course new york
times bestseller right out of the gate
love
people use things because the opposite
never works a 20 city tour coming up
listen real careful
these are venues that sell out when
these guys come to town
to do a podcast and do a talk and a book
reading and
audience q a people love hanging out
with them and you can tell why just
listening but these always sell out so
listen careful
almost every one of you almost every one
of these cities are
uh we're broadcasting in so san antonio
ding ding houston dallas salt lake city
denver phoenix orlando atlanta nashville
d.c new york city almost sold out
already they told me
what came out this weekend available
boston vancouver seattle
san francisco los angeles toronto
columbus
chicago and minneapolis only two of the
20 cities are not hearing me say that
right now
so you guys the check it out you want to
go to minimalists.com
tour to get your tickets and it'll be a
great
evening you'll come away not shamed
you will come away thoughtful about the
role
that stuff plays in our lives and you
always do when you watch their
documentaries
when you read their books or when you
attend their events so minimalist.com
slash tour to get your tickets
now this is the second book third book
it's believe it or not it's the fourth
yeah the fourth book
yes i'm sorry i should know these things
i should have prepped better i'm so
sorry
so i i my prediction was going to be um
i thought it was at least the second
that this is going to be your biggest
one and uh
some of the stuff as i was thumbing
through it and of course you know i'm
going to gravitate to the money chapter
money is not the root of all evil and
you guys are not against
uh wealth building yeah um and
um the fun one in there is you get the
same you get everybody
in our world gets a line that that
everybody thinks is original
and they come up to you and they always
come up to me and make some lame joke
about a credit card right mm-hmm
and they come up to you guys and go i
was a minimalist one so i grew up poor
yeah you know and you guys hear that
like every third person in a book line
right
right yeah and so minimalism is not
poverty and it's not an
advocate you're not advocating poverty
and you're not calling
nice things even um evil
no not at all i mean minimalism sounds
like a really radical lifestyle
but you know the way we look at it is
it's really just a practical
lifestyle because let's say everyone
stops spending money right now
the economy will crash right and then
if we go to the other side of it and we
spend way too much as as we saw in 2008
the economy crashes so really i think
minimalism is that middle ground
approach
to spending money to bringing things
into your life and it's not just
you know physical possessions yes we
talk about that but really relationships
jobs there's so many things that we
don't really
sit and ask why we bring these things
into our lives and i think that's what
minimalism really helps people do is get
to the root
of why how might your life be better
with less how might your life be better
with that job how might your life be
better with that that person in your
life
and uh yeah that's so minimalism really
gets to the why i think that's a good
way to say it
i'm personally experiencing a different
version
of your material than i ever have before
right this second um
and i'm starting to kind of have the
theory and you probably have already
espoused this theory but i'm just
observing it in myself
that that um things can start out
serving a purpose yes and after a season
they need to go absolutely like we just
we've got this big
fabulous house that sharon and i built
uh 12 years ago
and it's it's amazing i mean and we've
had
charity events up there that have raised
more money for ministries and for
charity than the house costs so it's
been a good return on investment for god
okay he made money on it
and so and we've got to live there too
that was pretty cool you know
so but it's it's run its course yes and
so we sold we sold it the other day oh
wow and so we're going to be moving in a
couple months
which has led to cleaning out the
closets right yeah and you go in there
and you go
why do i have all this crap and it's
kind of but these things when they
started 12 years ago including the house
itself
yeah had a purpose but they've lived
they've outlived their season
yeah and they need to go yeah it's so
important you say that because
minimalism is not this destination
i wish we could like sit here and write
out like well you're moving to a new
place dave well let's write out the
hundred things that you need and the
hundred things that your wife needs and
and since you'll be you know living in
wherever here's another list of 50
things it just
doesn't work that way minimalism is a
way to kind of help you call it's really
to help you uh just get clear on what
adds value today what adds value
tomorrow because yeah it is so important
to recognize
the things in my life today may not add
value tomorrow and vice versa and that's
okay
yeah my daughter's eight she doesn't
still play with the same toys she did
when she was three right
yeah the average kid actually has 300
toys they play with about 12 daily
of course we as adults were the same
thing we have our own toys right
now we they they sort of we pretend
they're important things
but the truth is that a lot of those
things they did add value for a season
but they stopped adding value and so
minimalism is also that process where we
constantly question we keep asking
ourselves
does this serve a purpose does this add
value to my life
and if not we've got some rules in there
that will help you sort of let go
of the excess stuff because letting go
is not something that you do
letting go is something you stop doing
you stop clinging
to the excess stuff you stop clean to
the past or to toxic relationships
or to the way you wish things would be
dr don john colony talks about that all
the time grieve the past and move on
you know this thing this the the you had
this thing painted in your mind though
it was supposed to be in it
it's not that way yeah and so let's just
grieve that and take a step on
that's right you know let's just move on
and and and deal with that
so very very cool so hoarding is like
the extreme
opposite because it that's a that is not
a
it's a physical manifestation of of a
psychological problem
yeah that is really the it's the
ultimate out of control
consumer materialist yeah let's talk
about hoarding there's five stages of
hoarding we write about it a bit in the
book
and the truth is we're all hoarders to
some extent oh yeah
i figured it out clean on my dad for the
last three weeks i'm like
why have i i've not seen even seen this
in three years
why is it here the minimalists are going
to kill me
in the book we we took 40 47 different
families they did ryan's packing party
experiment
where they box up everything in their
house they pretend like they're moving
because as you just
illuminated here as soon as we move it's
the one time in our lives
we're forced to deal with all of those
indiscretions
all of those things that we purchase the
things that we thought were going to
make us happy we don't even remember
so those objects of our desire they soon
over
a couple years they become the objects
of our discontent
and so when that happens it's it's just
time to let go
so this is a great time for you to be
decluttering yeah yeah well i'm so
freaking organized in ocd about
everything else because i don't have
clutter clutter
but then when you dig behind the layer
you find it back there and i'm going
it's
disgusting yeah organizing doesn't work
organizing is one of the problems it's
the reason
i have a big problem with like the
container store and these other places
they sell us things to help us
hide our clutter
we have well-organized clutter exactly
and so organizing is often just
planned hoarding i was the same way i
was a well organized hoarder so i had
those 300 000 items
and they were neatly stored in an
ordinal system of bins and boxes and
alphabetized
i bet it was completely i bet it was
just as ocd as i am i thought it was the
same one yeah oh yeah
yeah i remember taking trips with him to
walmart to get the bins and yeah yeah
yeah
and they all got labels oh he has a
little machine label machine yeah yeah
yeah
he's that guy yeah i love that now i
would have to hire somebody no
i don't know this is great love
people use things so this is
got an element to it of just being
intentional
to keep things in their place a
sub category way below relationships
which are really all that matters
yeah that is the truth and that's the
way you guys have laid this out
yeah yeah i mean the the stuff is just
the initial bite at the apple
it leads to so much more because now we
have to decide
what we do with our time what we do with
our attention what we do with our money
i mean money
we look at it as being the most
important resource and it is an
important resource
but it's really our time and attention
that and the only thing that's good for
us what it does
yeah very good stuff
thanks for coming by guys hey thanks for
having us love these guys the minimalist
dot com slash tour for the 20 city tour
don't miss it
pick up the new book you will love it
called love people use things because
the opposite
never works this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host
the rest of this hour in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt-free stage
which can only mean one thing matthew
and brooke are with us welcome guys how
are you
awesome how you doing welcome welcome
where do you guys live indianapolis well
welcome to nashville and all the way
here to do a debt-free screen
yes sir how much have you paid off 97
362. i like it dangerously close to 100
000.
and how long did this take you 39 months
okay
good and your range of income during
that three years fifty thousand dollars
up to about 120. whoa somebody get a job
a few of them yeah okay oh yeah so i
mean because that's a sizeable increase
in three years like you
uh over doubled your income well yeah we
needed to
yeah we did so um we had uh at that time
i got a new full-time job
and then uh just kind of worked my way
up through some promotions and then at
the same time
we knew we needed more money so i
started a side hustle in a handyman
business and
and that just really took off over about
three years wow and brooke you're a full
is single mom full-time mom a single mom
you're a single mom because he works all
the time but no you're a full-time mom
um yes and then um about a year ago i
started working at
my kids preschool oh that's cool okay
very good what kind of debt was the 97
000 mostly student loan um there was
about 10
grand that was the vehicle in medical
but most of it probably
uh 9 85 80 was about student loan yep
yeah what do you do for a living man
i'm a director of operations at a
medical instrument company okay okay
very good good for you guys thank you
very neat
so what made you decide to do this 39
months ago how long y'all been married
17 years okay good thank you yeah so 14.
way to go brooke and uh so after 14
years of marriage approximately 13 years
of marriage you look up and you went
something's got to change what happened
so in uh 2009 2010 we we actually went
through financial peace university
uh and at that point we were really
committed to not get further into debt
but we had a real income issue i was in
ministry at the time and and
we didn't have a lot of money coming in
and we weren't gazelle intense on that
front
so we really lived within our means and
brooke was incredible with just you know
the budget and keeping things tight at
the home and all that stuff but
when we transitioned out of ministry
about 2016. we knew that
um there was a vision god had for our
lives but that couldn't be a part of it
so that's when we got really serious and
just
put the put our money where our mouth
was so to speak and went for it you
found out you can't
save your way out of debt exactly
exactly yeah you have to you have to
live on less than you make
yeah it doesn't work otherwise and you
tried the other direction first
we did very cool so who had that first
conversation with who
jeez probably you with me i think i
think i i didn't realize
how stressful uh that looming debt was
uh in our marriage and over my wife and
so uh finally i figured it out
through a lot of conversation and and i
realized that we need to do something
and uh so we got serious yeah i like how
you said that i finally figured it out
after she told you 120 times
excellent exactly yeah so so brooke what
did you uh
say because people call all the time
they go how do i get my wife on board
how do i get my husband on board how did
you get your husband on board
um harassing him
no just um just telling him it was a
concern and
you know asking what what can we do and
yeah because i was
very stressed out about it a lot so um
yeah just having a lot of conversations
about it so
you know what i heard him say and if i
put words in your mouth you correct me
it's okay i will
but i think i heard him say i love my
wife and i didn't know
how much she was carrying how much
weight she was carrying by herself and
once i understood that i was ready to go
absolutely absolutely that's what i
heard yeah thank you yeah
a lot of these guys a lot of these guys
and gals that are not on board
they don't know what it's doing to the
other one how much stress they're
carrying yeah
and and if they ever knew they would
stop they would you know oh let's fix it
then
because i don't i don't want my wife to
be miserable right but as long as
as long as i can continue to get away
with what i'm getting away with it's
okay though
right right yeah and i think the the
conversation was really more of
a uh how do what do we need to sacrifice
to do this
and not only with spending because like
i said we really weren't spending
living well within our means but it was
okay there's gonna be a lot of time
sacrifices and other things that we both
have to be on board with and like you
said
kind of being a single mom for a while
as i was working 90 hours a week
100 hours a week sometimes you know to
try to get this debt under control
yeah was it worth it absolutely
absolutely absolutely
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is 97
039 months is impressive stay with it
you know i think uh
we would listen all the time to the
ramsey show and and we we were so
encouraged
there are also times when you'd hear
people that were hey we were you know
two hundred thousand dollars in debt and
six months later we paid it off and
we're just like man you gotta be kidding
me right you know so
i think though that um that was also
encouraging too and if they could do it
we knew we could
and uh having brooke as my partner was
incredible because i think there are
days when i didn't want to keep going
and she did and she didn't want to keep
going i didn't i think just being
together and having that unity and that
shared vision
was the key so there's a rumor that if
you have one two
three four kids and you try to do this
um
and you can't give them million dollar
birthday parties that they die
right or if they can't have the fanciest
of all new
everythings that they just won't make it
and i see four beautiful
new family tree branches is that true or
not true
uh they survived yeah they need to tell
about it yeah they look beautiful and
doing they seem to be breathing just
fine
exactly yeah so um yeah i think you know
for us uh
they live like no one else so you can
live like no one else you know we were
we were doing
100 camping vacations you know over the
last two years and all those kind of
things and
uh we just got back from colorado on our
big debt-free vacation last week so
they're a little tired still from that
but uh but it's awesome to be on the
other side of that
yeah yeah you vacate like no one else
later you can vacate like
right absolutely yeah that was it yeah i
love it man very cool
good for you guys thank you so proud of
you thank you thank you man thank you
for
what you guys what you do well you guys
are you're why we're here and you you
you just
did an amazing thing so i don't want you
folks out there listening to miss this
they look so
like together and so calm and so
peaceful and all that but this guy's
been working 89 hours
for three years yeah i'm looking like
she's got
four kids two exhausted yeah it's like
that's marathoners just collapsed after
the finish line they did it we did
you know yeah what that what they gave
up in order to
get freedom for the next several decades
was was time effort money and it's hard
on both of them that's exactly right
they paid a price here to win there's a
hustle and grind here at an exponential
level because 97
000 in three years making this kind of
money oh and by the way in the process
of doing that very intentionally on the
day job
and on the side job did things to make
more money got a bigger shovel got more
shovels
yeah very intentional here so these
things do not you don't
you can wander into that you cannot
wander out right and you guys you were
my point is that i want everybody here
how intentional you were you squeezed
every penny once it got home
and you kept bringing more and more and
more home and that get the differential
that margin is what got you out of that
97
039 months this is powerful and there's
four little kids out there that are not
going to carry around those
bricks because of the three years y'all
put in good for you
man yeah all right let's bring them up
what are their names and ages
all right i'm in on the screen here so
is 12.
tinley is almost 10. paisley is almost 8
and kendall just turned 6.
all right well happy birthday kendall
good stuff fun
stuff all right and they've been
practicing all the way from indianapolis
if you'll turn up your radio turn up
your podcast device right now just a
little bit
you will get to hear one of the most
unusual sounds you'll ever hear you
actually get to
hear a family tree being changed yeah
right here right now very cool stuff all
right matthew and brooke warwick tinley
paisley and kendall
97 000 paid off in
39 months making 50 to
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
ready three two one
look at those smiles [ __ ] man
that's it powerful powerful stuff
you gotta have a big why and they got
four beautiful ones
and uh you have a reason to sacrifice to
win to live
like no one else so that later you can
live and give
like no one else no discipline seems
pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest
of righteousness they're walking in
scriptural truth right there
you can i just looking at them and i
can't take my eyes off them they just
their shoulders are down yeah they're
breathing a normal person yeah
they probably have slept in the last few
nights i'm so proud of them
yeah where you going freedom and its
peace amazing family
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
great
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions again
on the debt free stage
andrew and anne are with us hey guys how
are you
outstanding dave great to be here well
we're honored to have you where do you
guys live
we're in exton pennsylvania which is
philadelphia area oh fun
welcome to nashville thank you all the
way here to do a debt free scream how
much did you pay off
dave we paid off our 300 000 mortgage in
five and a half years
i'm looking at weird people some of the
weirdest 100
debt-free what was your range of income
during that five and a half years we
made about 178
to 230. very cool what do you guys do
for a living so i work in clinical
research
at a pharmaceutical company i write uh
drug submission documents
cool and i'm a stay-at-home mom okay
wonderful
wonderful welcome guys so good to have
you and congratulations what's this
house worth
this market i'd say 525 550 somewhere in
that range
all year yes sir
i love it have you had a month where you
got paid and you hadn't didn't have to
write that check
so april was the first month with no
mortgage payment wow
what was that like it's pretty sweet man
i gotta tell you after about you know 12
13 years of uh mortgage payments being
able to to set that aside is
is quite a quite a victory wow so what
made you guys decide to go on this
journey
to become a hundred percent debt free
house and everything yeah dave so
really our story starts back in 2007 we
were one or two years out of college at
that point
both of us graduated with student debt
and we did
what everyone has to do after you
graduate we finance brand new cars of
course both of us mandatory yeah
absolutely and then uh in addition in
2007 i bought our first
house uh put zero down took a
401k loan out to pay the closing costs
and uh it was 2007 my brother nick gave
me the total money makeover book
and read that at the beach that summer
and uh
that was my oh crap moment yeah that's
not a great vacation gift to me
yeah it's like uh runs a vacation and
everything
yeah you figure out everything you've
been doing wrong and so i was
downloading to ann
on a daily basis and you know day after
day was like
this is a practical plan we need to
submit ourselves to this plan yeah and
at that time i had
90 000 in student loan debt and a brand
new car that i financed and
i was like drowning in debt but didn't
know what to do and
um so as soon as he told me about it i
was like oh this is what i need and so
immediately i did the budget and i just
felt like
a weight a little bit of a weight had
been lifted like the light at the end of
the tunnel was very small but i could
see it and so it was super motivating
way to go you guys yeah so how long have
you been in this journey
in total so in 2007 we started we
cleared our consumer debt in 2013
we bought our current home in 2015 and
paid it off in five and a half years so
we've been
14 14 years yeah yeah wow wow tmmo's
been hanging around with you guys a long
time
yeah yeah way to go so with this much of
a journey
over this many years how do you stay
after it for that
long most people quit yeah
you know we just kept our eye on the
ball we wanted to be debt free we didn't
want the burden
of being in debt we want to be able to
you know give more
generously and that's a big motivator
for us
yeah i mean praying for contentment
to us you know contentment is is the key
to getting out of debt
being satisfied in in the walk
the the life that you've chosen while
you know
others might be buying brand new cars
remodeling their homes doing all these
things that
we wanted to do as well but we
prioritized getting out of debt first
and foremost
and contentment can be quite difficult
because you're what you're doing
is is unseen you know you can't see it
versus
the scene which is american you know
consumer
materialism is all in your face exactly
and contentment's nowhere near to be
seen
nowhere yeah you can't find it it's just
a it's a sense of it's a spiritual
position yeah yes sir yeah
and people at your office thought you
were crazy for what you drove right
and i there was one new year's eve where
someone had hit my car you know trying
to drive home
i assume and uh yeah so i had a little
bit of a
a bumper uh busted bumper for a little
bit
but uh no more yeah anything you want to
do now
yeah very cool very cool what do you
tell people the key
to getting out of that is uh budgeting i
mean you can't get anywhere without a
plan
and we've done it every month since we
started
and for 14 years and we'll never not do
it because you know
we tell our money where to go it doesn't
tell us where to go so yeah
yeah got to know your numbers budgeting
is the key and
like we said contentment man be
satisfied
in your plan because it's going to pay
dividends and
you know and who would have thought 14
years ago that you look up now and you
make 20 000 bucks a month and you have
no payments at all in the world
that's so much money it's unbelievable
i mean it's just yeah very very cool
so you brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages yes sir our
daughter mae is eight years old and our
son ava
is four years old about to be five in
august yeah so of course they came along
during this journey sure did absolutely
yeah very cool and it changes the shape
of things as well
also kind of increases the uh the why
we're doing this it stops it stops being
about you as far as being about we're
going to change our family tree
that's right totally the y evolved over
time without a doubt yeah that's
very cool copy the legacy journey for
you my latest book uh
on you know what it feels like to live
and
leave a legacy which you guys have
definitely done and another copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away to somebody
maybe you can ruin their beach vacation
appreciate it pay it forward for them
yeah very cool you guys we're very proud
of you you're impressive people
thank you so very well done you got to
feel accomplished we do we do
well congratulations i hope those two
little it's may i want you to
recognize you are in the presence of two
rock stars and i know you
you call them mommy and daddy but
they're heroes to the rest of us that's
awesome
absolutely very good and you too ava
yeah you too
all right andrew and may and avid from
the philadelphia area
300 000 paid off house and
everything over the last five and a half
years
making 178 to 2 30. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
same time three two one
[Applause]
how fun is that
that's fun man that's so cool
that's amazing that's a couple of them
in a row there
we worked them into this hour because
we've got some other stuff going on in
the other hours today to make but we had
to get so we make sure both of them get
because both of them made trips here and
we don't want to leave them hanging
after that to do their debt-free screams
but
pretty stinking incredible and you know
this is just all about
a decision to be intentional and then
they made it part of their life this is
fourteen and a half years they've been
on this
rhythm now right with student loans and
why we're here let's go ahead and pay
the house off and
um and i love you put gas in the car you
make your bed you do a budget that's
part of the rhythm of your life yeah
but both families here had little kids
and both little kids sets are all
breathing and smiling
and joyful and mom and dad were
joyful and they seem to be well
nourished yes
everybody has all their limbs and
they're all wearing shoes it's it's this
perception
oh we can't do it because of this or we
can't do because it's not true
no you can do anything you want to do
it's right are you willing to pay the
price
and you know oftentimes when we're
setting a goal
uh it's not what we're willing to do
it's what we're willing to give up
that causes you to hit the goal or not
hit the goal um i mean you gotta you're
gonna have to you're gonna have to pay a
price
you're not going to pay off 300 000 in
five and a half years
without giving up some things uh it goes
with the territory but if you live like
no one else later
and they got 20 a month income now and
not a payment
in the world do you understand how
wealthy they're going to be
oh man i mean tens of millions of
dollars just simply investing the house
payment for the next 25 years
college which for those little ones will
be about a million dollars a semester by
the time they get there
it will just be annoying right it's
going to be an annoyance
like ah that's a bummer all right where
you you know what i mean yeah like
it's not a deal breaker anymore guys i'm
so proud of you guys congratulations
well done dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host
today james childs is our producer kelly
daniel is our associate producer
and phone screener folks you can do this
stuff
we know you can do it we've seen you and
people just like you do it
all the time be sure and check it out
[Music]
ramsaysolutions.com this is the ramsey
[Music]
show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today best-selling author
and host of the dr john delony show
he talks on the show about life about
anxiety about boundaries about
relationships
and we will uh take your questions all
in the mental health side of things
as well as the money side of things this
hour we're here to help you with your
life and your money the phone number is
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
jake is with us in dallas texas hi jake
how are you
doing how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so uh about a year ago me my wife well
we had some stupid we had still had to
get out of our system uh we'd been
married for about 20 minutes and of
course had to buy a house
and we didn't have a whole lot of money
for it so we didn't put 20 percent down
we put closer to 5
down and now we have a job offer that's
about 50 60 miles away
so we're gonna be moving out of that
house and i'm wondering should we
because i've kind of been interested in
real estate and running a rental
property business
because this is in a college challenge
should i still kind of keep this house
since you might be upside down if we try
to sell it while the fee is included
or should i just try and throw as much
money as it uh
as i can to be able to sell it and
profit a little bit
yeah well it's not profit it's just a
matter of whether you write a check when
you sell it it's all
so get with one of our real estate elps
at ramseysolutions.com find out what
your reality is
this market is so hot my guess is you're
going to get out of it
that's my guess and here's the thing if
you were living 50 miles away and
working a new job
you would not call me up and say hey
dave
i want to buy a house 50 miles away with
nothing down
leverage it all the way up to what oh as
much on it as it's worth
which means the rent is barely if at all
going to cover the payment
and so i really want to take on this
liability 50 miles away
nothing down by the way you wouldn't do
that that's effectively what you got
here
house has got no equity in it and by the
time you rent it
for uh you're barely going to cover the
payment and by the time it's vacant a
time or two
and then the heat and air burps on you
you're going to have
a loss for the year this thing is a
problem
it is not a blessing
and i just heard the other day that they
maybe today that they reinstated the
mass mandate in california and some
place like
you're one cove it away your one
tick uptick in numbers etc for colleges
going back online and suddenly this
thing that feels like it's a surefire
bet in this college town
not being so sure fire anymore the guys
i know with college
real estate and it's not admittedly not
a lot they're getting out
just because it's so unsure uncertain
yeah
you don't know if the kids are ever
going to go back in that classroom again
or if they are
it's going to be an unstable and
volatile situation at best
so in and out in and out depending on
who's panicking where
and where we're going to overreact again
but
anyway that's that's just a shot do you
have a do you have a
i i wrote a check one time to get out of
the house
i think i took 4 500 bucks or something
to closing
and that next 18 months we ended up
paying off six figures of student loan
debt
but it was a painful check it was hard
to write
but it was what was right for an
upcoming season that ended up freeing us
forever um is it ever okay it's i felt
good about writing that check even
though i didn't feel good about it does
that make sense yeah well it was the
right thing to do
right so i mean if you lost 450
a month for um 10 months you'd have
broke even but it's not going to be that
bad
probably but you're probably going to
lose that much on a house in a year
if you're fully leveraged on it and we
know you're fully leveraged because you
didn't make any money
above the mortgage so meaning that your
payment is so stinking
high because you've got the most
borrowed possible on it that
that the rent is going to be right there
at it and so and you put in the realtor
fee and then you're stuck
and your breakeven is just not there so
what you don't want to do is i'm losing
six hundred dollars a year and so
i'm gonna panic and write a hundred
thousand dollar check no yeah you know
we don't go that far
on the way but but most of the time and
here's the thing
i've always wanted to own rental real
estate you don't want to own rental real
estate
that you owe as much on it as it's worth
because it does not make money
right and this is not fun this is me
this is going through all the hassles of
real estate and making no money
that's that that's rental real estate
that's fully leveraged there's no fun in
here anyway
oh well 30 years from now the renter
will have paid it out and bull crap
you know that's just that's not how this
works
uh ravika is with us in new york city hi
ravika how are you
hi gabe my name is riska thank you i'm
sorry riff god
butchered your daughter i apologize no
problem it's not an easy name but thank
you so much for taking my call
um so my question is my husband and i
live in brooklyn
okay you you haven't stopped you cut out
when you said my husband and i live in
brooklyn and that's all we heard
try again okay can you hear me now yes
ma'am
okay so i'm a public school teacher my
husband is a chef
we both make a decent living we're
currently on baby steps 3b
we're saving for a down payment on a
house and
the more i think about the possibility
of buying a house in new york
the more i think about how it's a
catch-22 where
um we'll have to factor in the cost of
property taxes the cost of housing is
astronomical
and it just seems like that we're going
to sacrifice
our decent living for our quality of
life
less time will be spent with family and
um you know now in new york city they're
mandating um
that teachers and all city workers get
the coven vaccine
so it just it just seems like they give
you a little bit of freedom
and then they take it away and so i'm
just wondering at what point
would you say it's okay to get up leave
new york and
move somewhere else
you've already moved yeah you you
already lived you're gone
there's nothing that you described here
that's staying the only part the only
thing that's
that's left is your broken heart because
you actually love the people in the area
you've got family in the area your
history in the area
and your heart is hurting but you
already left you're gone
the every day you stay from this point
forward is a decision to be a little
less joyful
right absolutely yeah you get you've
already
analyzed it because anytime we're going
to leave or
uh you know leave a job leave a
relationship leave anything
uh henry cloud talks about this in the
book necessary endings
which you might want to pick up by the
way it'd be a nice this isn't one of my
top five of all time
yeah henry's a good friend of john's and
mine both and just a great guy
but in necessary endings he says you end
a relationship
with a place a job an item
a person a whatever
when you lose hope that it's going to
get better
right and so in after the anytime after
you've lost hope that it's going to get
better
it's now lacking in intelligence and
wisdom to continue to
i mean he's not going to beat me anymore
he's not going to beat me anymore no i
know he's going to beat me
then it's time to end this relationship
you've lost hope that it's going to get
better
even in a toxic situation you've lost
hope that's going to get better and
well you the reason john and i jumped on
this so fast is you very much described
that you have lost hope
that this is going to get better they've
taken your freedoms the prices are too
high
there's nothing there that the good
things there have been outweighed by the
bad things
long before you made this phone call in
your mind
so you've already made the call now you
need to act on it you all have a funeral
and then go living somewhere fun
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
today this is the ramsey show when it
comes to making big money
or life moves like buying a house
getting married having a baby it's
likely the last thing on your mind to
make sure you have the right insurance
coverage
i understand that big changes are
overwhelming
but what would be even more overwhelming
is to find yourself in a mess with no
insurance
don't do this if not having the time or
energy is what's keeping you from
getting the right insurance company
coverage get with one of our endorsed
local providers
our elps these are independent agents
who will shop among a gazillion
companies get you the best coverage at
the best price
for your home your auto any of your
insurance needs check them out
all you got to do is text insurance to
33 789
the person who does typically saves
around 700 a year
doesn't cost a thing to get a quote
though worst case scenario doesn't say
anything when you walk on right
text insurance to 33789
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free
with free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from rita in
illinois she says we are debt-free
including her home and have a 1 million
dollar net worth
all the credit for our financial
security goes to my husband
he's very focused and intentional but
he's so focused on saving that we can't
enjoy life we recently went on a
vacation and i begged him to let me take
my daughter and her friend by myself so
he could stay home
it was a miserable trip our most
expensive meal was 70 bucks for four
people and he had a meltdown
spending money affects his mood so badly
that we choose not to do
things that we enjoy how can i encourage
him to stop
worrying about every penny
wow dave there's a lot here
yep just at the beginning of this thing
when she says all the credit for the
financial security goes
to my husband i want to stop that
conversation right there and say no it
doesn't
right y'all been working on this
together somehow he's taken all the
credit
and he's also gets all of the blame here
um sounds like somebody wrapped his
identity around scarcity
right and did not get the most important
thing i think
of being a net worth millionaire is now
you can give like nobody else
right and so is living in this scarcity
scarcity scarcity mindset never enough
never
enough this is mine this is mine um
i know several people like this and i
can be like this if i
am not doing well right and it's all
back to that
i work this is mine and there's scarcity
it can never sometimes it can run out
and i'm just going to be in a mess
how do you encourage somebody there this
is a psychological issue this is not
just about money
right on a practical tactical level
here's what's not happening the two of
you are not
sitting down together and looking at a
monthly budget and both of you have a
vote
he is a control freak he is dictating
everything
and you are going along with every bit
of it you don't have a voice you don't
have a vote
and then he shows you the net worth and
says look how happy you should be
right right look how good a job i did
and it's not his job to do it by himself
so the two of you we should work
together here's the thing
spenders opposites attract larry burkett
used to say if two people just like get
married one of you is unnecessary
opposites attract spenders attract
savers
nerds attract free spirits people that
are late
attract people that are 15 minutes early
oh i mean opposites
attract they just attract and that's a
good thing
you need each other and it's that old
cheesy jerry
maguire you complete me thing right and
it's but that's it you really do it's a
complementary
relationship and the problem is half of
your relationship's not working
you you yep you got no voice
the part that's supposed to bring joy to
this equation is you
the free spirit that enjoys money is you
you're supposed to help him with that
and so um
that's part of your job my wife is the
natural saver at our house
and i'm in charge of fun
and so i have to remind her that there's
a
balance between the wisdom to do a good
job of intentionally managing money
saving and investing it
and also have a category in the budget
when you're a millionaire
to enjoy your money and that's one to
the
especially to the husbands out there
that live this life stop
give her give her a voice stop it yeah
sharon's voice
speaking into our marriage has caused us
to save more
my voice has caused us to enjoy and
increase generosity more because
spenders are generally generous
and so the problem is is that you don't
have a voice yeah that's what's really
going on here there's a lot of control
freaking in the way you
in between the lines of these words i
think no question about it and
again my default setting is to ask what
about this
relational dynamic makes him have to
control freak and at the same time
man i want to take guys like this and
just shake them and say stop
what are you doing what are you doing
all this for if you're not going to take
your daughter and your wife and a friend
out to dinner
like the most sacred events is meal time
together right
exactly teresa's in boston mass hey
teresa what's up in your world
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure
how can i help um my ques my question i
think is more for dr delany
um my husband and i have been working
you know for years and years and years
and working two jobs getting ahead
getting things done
and just how can we
be okay with seeing all the people
taking the unemployment
people taking the government payoffs and
not just covered stuff but
for years we see this going on it's
frustrating
um it's hard you know when we're just
working and doing it all on our own and
we see
potentially kind of freeloaders all
around us
sir you asking me
i will tell you i mean adjust my
attitude yeah i'll tell you what i tell
my five-year-old daughter
when she comes and says hank her older
brother
is doing this and this and that and this
and i tell her
josephine you take care of you
ta-da any decision to look into someone
else's world or situation
and choose to let your perception of
their world
impact your day as a choice that you are
choosing to poison your day hoping that
they get sick from it and i wish it was
more difficult than that it's a choice
is it frustrating to think and fantasize
about what they're not doing or what
their life situation is or why they are
or not
yeah it feels good and it feels in it
you know it's a
righteous indignation right it feels
good yeah but the truth is
the the freeloader stats and all this
kind of
you don't know what their world is it's
just an imagination is it frustrating to
have taxes taken out oh my gosh it's a
beating i hate it and it is
and when i drive on a road and with a
pothole on it i want to get into
all that stuff is me choosing to have a
less good
day and so what i would tell you the
same thing i tell josephine is
you take care of you and if you and your
husband decide to wake up tomorrow and
start looking for where you are driving
on roads you didn't build and when
police officers that you didn't hire
show up to your house and
you can look for things to be positive
about
or you can let this thing just bury you
so theresa i um suffer from exactly the
same
illness it pisses me off
i'm with you i'm with you okay i don't
like it
uh to john's point i had to make a
decision a few years ago so
i by getting in the business that i'm in
and getting up in the spotlight and
everybody have an opinion about me now
um it made me less intense about having
an opinion about other people
[Laughter]
because everybody's pissed off about
something i'm doing all the time i'm
just telling you okay
i can't wear the right shirt i can't
live in the right house i can't vote the
right way i can't say
the right thing i'm not christian enough
i'm too christian i mean there's
something
all the time somebody's bitching about
when it comes to old dave and so what
that helped me with was i thought
i just realized um you know what it's
none of their business
and so me worrying about these other
people is none of my business
and it helped me to kind of go i'm not
going to spend all my time being one of
those guys
because they're cut all those guys are
coming at me twitter trolls and whatever
else right and so i'm
you know i just thought you know what
i'm gonna spend all my time
lifting things up adding value that's
right and
less time being mad but but my nature is
to do exactly what you're talking about
kiddo
i don't disagree with you but it helped
me to get pounded by
people doing the same thing towards me
that's right help me
to go i'm not doing that anymore it
takes too much of my energy
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today bestselling author and
host of the dr
john de lumie show we talk about life
and
anxiety and boundaries and relationships
in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage jamie and diana
are with us hey guys how are you
good wonderful good where do you guys
live in northeast pennsylvania
oh fun well good to have you welcome to
nashville and all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
well first original state um this is all
my story
we've been married only three months oh
wow congratulations
oh congrats well thank you thank you and
so um i paid off
183 000. okay wow excellent and how long
did it take you to do that uh 30 months
wow so diane came into the marriage with
no debt okay
all right and you did too yeah yeah
actually i
became debt free uh a week before we got
married yeah so
it's a break even i don't know how we
got there but we both got there right
yeah
so okay how long did it take 30 months
to do 183 what was your range of income
during that two and a half years you
were doing this
well this is where i have a long story
but um
i did a lot of stupid and in 2008 i'm
self-employed
and my income was only like 15 000.
because i was living off credit cards i
drained my retirement account
and then this year my income will be
over 200 well over 200
wow and it's it's growing every year wow
what do you do for a living
i'm a financial advisor okay all right
sounds like a lot of life transformation
in that yeah in that lump in your throat
i heard
yeah there was there was i went through
a lot of trials and i did
like i said i did a lot of stupid yeah
me too brother that's how i can hear it
so quickly
i know that feeling my voice starts
what kind of debt was and eighty three
thousand oh 160 of it was credit card
and then the rest was some loans uh back
spousal support
i was mad at the world i refused to pay
it and i finally came to terms with it
got that cleared up um some i owed back
grant i have two offices i will
background on two locations i got that
all caught up
how much of the 183 was back spousal
support
uh it was probably at the peak
was like five to five thousand it wasn't
much no no no it was
most of the most of this was credit
cards 160 okay yeah so what were you
doing that ran up 160 000 worth of
credit cards
stupid i i i got that that's kind of
obvious but i mean
okay
so diane and i were jehovah's witnesses
and um i quit serving god
when i fell out of love in my first
marriage and i
lived a life of debauchery so i was just
like putting stuff on credit card i had
my staff was too high
i had my employment my rent was too high
so i was just charging stuff on credit
card
you know to make cash advances make
payroll so you were spiraling and it
showed up in the money
yeah that's what i thought i heard
earlier okay
i knew you'd been through something okay
and so where
where was the um the moment
where you turned this because because
it's more than about money you turned
your life
correct what turned it well i have two
grown children
and they're my why with it but i was so
broke
um i started doing uber at night and i
started listening to you
and so and i was like and you talked one
day about don't be a victim
be a victor and i played the victim for
a while i blamed the world
i didn't take their responsibility so
when i finally made that
change is that that's that's me i got to
do this i can do this it's up to my
my future's up to me not up to somebody
else
and then i thought about my kids and
what am i leaving them i was leaving
them nothing
now you left them a hero of an example
you took that
i mean you take control of the guy in
the mirror that's the most courageous
thing you can do
and those rains can be hard so what was
that moment for you what was the moment
you woke up and looked in the mirror and
said today's the day
no more i don't remember the exact
moment i remember like
dave talks about having that moment
you're crying in the shower
um i've had those because i would always
listen to your show every day
and those debt-free screams would get me
and i i would cry frequently
because i would say to myself that's me
i'm going to do that
i'm going to do that but the moment it's
hard to define
the moment i had several turning points
in
in there that happened that i can
mention but sure and how long
how how long have you and diana been
seeing each other
uh just over a year then we got married
in april okay well congratulations again
so danny you
you caught him in the middle of a
whirlwind huh yes i did i'm like who are
you
what is going on yeah yeah but you
caught him on
really he was on the way out by the time
you saw him yeah so you could see where
this was going in a positive way
absolutely yeah very so somebody's
listening to this
millions of people but somebody is
listening to this
and they cried this morning on the way
to work and they're a tough guy and they
think they've got it all figured out
they're spinning 500 plates and
one's about to drop what would you tell
them
never give up it's not too late
i remember in an fpu i think it was less
than two
the old one we talked about dave you
mentioned about uh colonel sanders
didn't start doing chicken
until he's in his 60s grandma moses
started paying that that hit me
i'm in my 50s and here i am i'm at the
bottom right
it's never too late wow
fifteen thousand dollars to 200 plus
new marriage new life new outlook yeah
yeah it's a it's a whole thing in it
yeah it really is
yeah congratulations thank you very well
done you're a hero man
the money piece is this is the uh
byproduct
that's all it is of you changing you and
god getting involved in your life and
changing your life i mean this is
you turn back over to him and that's uh
and you know
and the bonus prize is diana
the getting out of debt is not the thing
in his story it's the thing that
happened
because he changed absolutely it happens
all the time that way but this one's
real severe but i sense in you
a courage to come up here and tell this
story that is not common
of a 50 plus year old man from northern
pennsylvania that fell on his face and
here you are in front of the whole
world saying i fell and i got back up
and it took some other people
but here i am and there's a level of
courage to you that's coming through
this conversation that is
that i want everyone to listen this to
hear it's conviction yeah
you're a strong powerful man and i'm
proud of you yeah
thank you okay it's awesome what you've
done thank you
and your kids and their kids and their
kids are gonna have their lives changed
because of what you did i'm proud of you
man yeah
and not not anything to do with the
money nope the money who cares about the
money
making 35 000 standing the way you're
standing and they'd still be proud of
you yeah
the exam it's awesome that's the example
well done
very well done hero all right i love it
we gotta
hit yourself just to a good one way to
go man and he hitched himself to a good
one too
exactly so we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because that's what
you've done you've changed your whole
life and your legacy and that's the next
chapter in your story to
finish this redemption story that is you
well done very well done i copy the
total money makeover to give away to
somebody who's just getting started
uh maybe they're crying in the shower or
driving their uber or whatever i don't
know you'll run into them you'll know
when
when you're supposed to give that book
away it'd be good stuff so very very
well done
and diane's gonna celebrate diana is
gonna celebrate with him
and scream as well jamie and diana from
pennsylvania 183
000 paid off in 30 months
making nowadays 200 up from
15. count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
he brought that one from his guts
well that's uh that's where it came from
that came from
inside that came from i came from a long
road
wow and you know but he he's right we
you know
dave i'm specialist you're speechless
there's time on this show when i know
that all these things i say
that i'm a freaking cheese factory and
then there's a time
that god is saying that and whispering
it directly in your ear that you are not
a victim you are a victor
that's right you can do what jaime did
you're not too old you're not too fat
you're not too late you're not too
whatever you think you are
you can you can do it ted is it gonna be
easy
no two days but it starts
because jamie was here today it starts
right now right and i'm talking to you
you and you know exactly who i'm talking
to
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america dr john
dolone ramsey personality is
my co-host today peak real estate season
is just around the corner
and this year things are different it's
we're living in peak real estate season
it's going to say what's that even what
does that mean home prices are crazy
competition between buyers is intense
crazy you mess up in a deal right now it
could be six figure mistake
this is not amateur hour you do not want
your uncle charlie who just got his
license and sold one house selling your
most expensive asset
dumb idea or your friend's sister no
charlie is a sweet guy
but he is not a pro and i don't care if
it makes your sister mad
no we're not doing it uncle charlie we
love you see you at christmas we're
going to get a real realtor okay
get a good one i mean get somebody sells
about a bazillion houses right
don't jump head first into something you
don't understand get with one of our
endorsed local providers they are all
high octane high protein
a monkey can sell a house in this market
but that does not mean it's going to
sell it for the most and not going to
mean you don't pay too much and don't
mean you'll get sideways in a wicked
weird deal
go to ramseysolutions.com agent get one
of our elps ramseysolutions.com
agent lindsay is in raleigh hey lindsay
welcome to the ramsey show hi
i'm so excited to be talking to you guys
you too what's up
um so my daughter is about to turn one
so this is kind of thinking far in
the future but we all you often talk
about how
more is caught than taught
and my husband and i grew up putting you
know watching our parents
put their tithe in the offering plate
and now my husband and i
are paying our ties like once a month
online so i was wondering if you had
any ideas short of starting to write
checks again
um no i would not our daughter
um you know how that we ties instead of
just talking about it
well what i did when uh
you know rachel and denise uh even
daniel but
more rachel and denise were uh 10 or 12
they graduated to sit at the kitchen
table when i
end quotes did the bills you know what
i'm talking about right
we used to sit down with a stack of
bills at the kitchen table with a
checkbook
and we had a check this thing called a
checkbook register and you would balance
the checkbook now this is a long time
ago those young women are in their 30s
now okay
so uh but no one does that anymore i
don't balance my checkbook
physically anymore it's done online
obviously
reconcile my checkbook you don't call it
balance anymore probably
but um and i don't pay my electric bill
with a check anymore but
but i remember distinctly denise my
oldest
the first time she had an aha moment and
it sounds like it's not much money today
but it was a long time ago
i wrote a check for 238 dollars for the
electric bill and she saw the amount and
i used to let them
write out the checks and then i would
sign them so the electric company would
get these
checks from a third grader you know it's
fabulous but they cash right so
and i would sign them and when she wrote
out 238 dollars her eyes got big and
she's like oh man
so i'm thinking to myself when you ask
this question what's the uh
modern day equivalent of letting your
kid pay the electric
bill so they have a dad no wonder you
tell us to shut the door cause it's 238
what's the modern day equivalent when
she did that because her eyes got big
and she's like suddenly understood
why i said you weren't raised in a barn
shut the dadgum door
you're letting your air conditioning in
the backyard like every one of us have
told every kid since
time began right and so um
but she's this little light bulb no pun
intended went on over her head and she
said okay this is expensive
same thing happens with giving when you
watched your parents put it in the tray
in the offering same thing happens with
rachel she makes she when she's doing a
talk on giving she talks about
remembering sitting on my knee or
sitting beside me in church we're all
dressed up back in the day used to
dressed up to go to church and you know
she watched me put the physical check in
like you're asking about
what's the modern day equivalent of that
i guess it's filling out the little
thing online with your
keyboard and hitting submit i can tell
you what we do in our house okay
and we we are intentional about cash
because i want them to see it
and so we actually do pull out a little
bit of money and sometimes you can at a
grocery store
um you can take 20 or 50 bucks over and
you know that way you don't have to go
to a bank
when you're just using your debit card
but we use the my kids both have
the ramsay banks here and it's become so
ingrained in our conversation they know
that the
giving how do they observe you giving oh
that's our question okay gotcha so
we teach them about saving and giving um
and they actually put it in the
collection plate but i
we sit down and and hank's old enough
now he's 11. uh he rolls his eyes
but he sits down and watches us pay the
bills and so he'll watch online
he'll watch us click it he'll show us
look at the budget this is how much
we're giving right
so the amount and in relation to
especially now that he knows here's what
he gets paid for mowing the yard
and that's how much electric call it and
that's how much are given to church
right that's how he starts to see that
but we sit down and he looks at the
computer screen with
it's called teaching them the value of a
dollar right it's an old saying that
dads used to say in the 50s
and those of us that are throwbacks
still say stuff like that so i think the
key here is not overthinking it
yeah but however you do it involve them
in that
rhythm yeah they need to because here's
the thing
hank's 11 and he has
never ex for him to experience a
checkbook would be more foreign than for
him to experience giving
so let him experience it the way he
experiences everything else in his life
which is freaking online
right you know so he's going to hit
submit and that's going to
that's going to penetrate his heart and
soul faster than
some weird analog version of something
we remember from our childhood
so let i mean the way he does
everything's online so why wouldn't he
do giving online but he also i want him
to participate in giving of his own
oh that's yeah that's that's building
their little muscle but she's saying
she saw more's caught than taught she
saw it modeled
how do i model it that's right and
that's what i'm that's what i'm leaning
in on so that's a
really really good question i love it
yeah and and of course the other thing
is this we're not going to make any of
this legalistic
it's all going to be we're trying to
create the spirit around this which is
what god was doing when he's taught us
to talk
and that's where the giving conversation
also i bring hank over
and let him see whenever we tip in a
restaurant
i want him to see what the bill was and
then how much we're tipping and i'm an
obnoxious
it's a big deal to me those people get
treated like trash and um
so i want it it's giving us a good
tipper yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah um i just want to be
clear yeah
i'll help you with your hate mail okay
thank you no i tip too much but i want
him to see that and it's an ethos of
giving like you said it's a way of
it's a way of living it's a way of
feeling the rhythm of life it's we hold
this with an open hand
that's right it's not mine it's not my
stuff called money is it's for
enjoyment and generosity and blessings
and
and you know and we save some of it why
so we can have more enjoyment and
generosity and blessings it's the only
point in raising your net worth right
it's not just because we want to
become a baby steps millionaire it's
wonderful but why but why what's up why
what's the point yeah so you can tip
outrageously wonderfully
yeah obnoxiously yeah that's a great one
i like that that's a good question
i love that question so i'd be
interested to see like rachel i need
i wish she was sitting here i would ask
her because i don't know
i mean i know they're teaching the kids
out of the financial piece how to do the
stuff
but i don't know how much they're
looking over like little amelia's
looking over winston or rachel's
shoulders when they're actually doing
their giving because i guarantee you
winston does that online oh yeah
i just wonder i just wonder in five ten
years well you walk through your living
room and say hey alexis in the church
a thousand dollars i'm not going to have
a lexus do anything in my life i'm not
me neither brother
they're listening to alexis listen to
the dave ramsey show
hey alexis listen to the ramsey show i
just turned on stuff everywhere in
america just then
it's actually a little thing one of
those little one of those little scripts
we put it in there it's awesome
if i just said hey alexis listen to john
dolone show it would say
sorry what show is that let's say
you and five no that's right 50 million
others i mean i've never seen anything
like your show take off
all kidding aside you always act like
there's four people listening when we
know there's millions our numbers say
how popular this show is
but that's a great that's a great segue
a great question because
here's the thing um
is there a certain technology that is
right or wrong
when it comes to handling your money no
there is not
what you've got to be careful with in
your own life and what you're modeling
before your kids
is what is it doing to your psyche
you know because anytime that the
technology makes it easier for you to
spend money and your brain does not
register
the pain that you've your pain centers
are not activated that you just did
spending
that's called low friction in marketing
and we make it really where you don't
feel the pain to buy something
you will buy more of it click click
click click click click click
uh prime deliver tomorrow we'll deliver
it this afternoon on your porch
that's right we wouldn't want you to be
inconvenienced by waiting even overnight
before the sun goes down
we will bring you stuff and oh by the
way did you notice that card that was
already registered in your little
prime account just got ding-dinged oh i
think i'll take two
i'll have three see that's a problem
that's a problem
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the box
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice today
this hour is an entree leadership
theme hour if you didn't know i have a
number one
new york times bestselling book called
entre leadership the combination of
entrepreneurism and leadership coming
together with energy and
a little bit of nobility together to
accomplish some business goals and
how we're going to run a business and do
it with dignity and do it with
class and so forth that's what entre
leadership is all about
so your questions about business this
hour dr john deloney ramsey personality
is my co-host
and what that means is the doctor is in
the house
and if dr dolone's here that means you
can talk about um your feelings and
stuff
and and if you're in business
you got some feelings after covet i'm
just saying
and not all of them are positive if
you're in business you got some feelings
about uh that customer you got some
feelings
i'm doing my southern thing here about
um
i love it whenever a grown man feels
uncomfortable
they slip into an accent because it
feels better is that what does i have to
do in alter ego you gotta have an alter
ego
it's awkward for me to have feelings
exactly i can't say i can't see feelings
as the feelings okay
all right so anyway so hey no not making
fun of you guys just
me okay so any of you want to talk about
your business on
any level dr john's here to help you
with the relational aspects the
stress aspects anxiety is real when you
run a business
all kidding and cutting up aside and uh
blustering to cover over the fact that
it's been a
year from hell and a lot of us have
experienced
stuff can you believe we're eight months
out of 2020.
i i couldn't believe it we sat down
sheila said hey we don't forget we can
do the budget here hey listen
when it's eight years out i'm still
gonna have that feeling in the back of
my
the base of my neck yeah that one where
i still just want to kill something that
feeling yeah that's that's still there
and i still have to be nice to people
even though they're
weird and so um my gosh and so this is
business right yeah
and so you want to talk about business
folks this hour this is your place
triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's an entree
leadership theme hour get in while you
can there's a couple lines open which is
highly unusual on the show
so this is your chance to get in paul's
in minneapolis hey paul how are you
i'm doing all right how are you doing
better than we deserve how can we help
you sir
um so a couple years ago um i got
screwed over pretty bad by a business
partner
and i was just trying to figure out the
best path to take to forgive them
what was the essence of the deal that
went bad and tell us about it
um we had a construction company and
basically i didn't
pay close enough attention to the
finances
um so a lot of money was spent out of
the business account for personal stuff
and how much is a lot
um several hundred thousand whoa
he bought himself some nice stuff
wow so he basically embezzled the
partnership
is that what you're saying yeah how did
you find out pretty much
um our taxes hadn't been done in a
couple years because that was supposed
to be his responsibility
and when i went through and um went
through all the bank statements that's
how i
realized the extent of the chaos
and that obviously ended the partnership
abruptly
yes okay and uh was there a discussion
of restitution at the time
of him paying back what was owed no no
i've actually never brought up eating i
mean you didn't you didn't say you owe
me this money back
no oh why uh it's family
what does that have to do with you
getting your money back
i guess i don't know i just didn't want
to press the issue
you know at that point the damage had
been done um
it's my sister and brother-in-law so is
your brother-in-law that did it
yes okay all right so what are you
looking forward to
with uh forgiveness i mean i'm assuming
this affects holidays this affects your
parents this affects everything huh
um yeah it affects mainly holidays um
we don't live near each other anymore so
we don't really see each other okay
what are you hoping to gain by
forgiveness
um i guess mainly the release from my
end
you know the financial part is what it
is you know i've moved on from that
but it's the resentment that creeps up
that i don't want
there's several things man we could talk
about this for an hour dave
you go ahead and talk no you have at it
i think there's a part of you that feels
had and
you i wish i had a better term and if i
had longer to think through it i would
use a kinder term
but you rolled over on yourself and
there's something about
forgiveness and there's something about
righteousness and justice
and then there's something about
fairness and whenever
i have walked away from a situation
especially
in the moment that's often the right
thing to do
not ever circling back and having the
conversation sometimes is hard because i
get disappointed in myself
um that i didn't x and y and z and i
how mad are you at paul yeah i sense
that in you
um very you know i could have stopped it
at any time so
yeah and for not looking over your
shoulder and knowing what the books were
doing and
not being more involved you you know you
handed it to him to do and walked off
and didn't keep up with it
exactly yeah you're a little pissed at
you i i can i can relate i've been there
myself yeah
so the first person that you're gonna
have to forgive is paul
and i in fact i just um
had some great insight this weekend i
think writing paul a letter in that
language
dear paul and writing yourself a letter
saying i forgive you
for the things you quote unquote should
have done you didn't know you trusted me
and you got burned it is what it is
but you got to let yourself off the hook
here and then
um i'm a big believer in forgiveness
but forgiveness is often if not always
for
you so i had a banker when i was going
broke
that completely was a crook and lied
and messed me over big time right in the
middle of me going broke
and so part of the exercise for me when
i went broke and i finally hit all the
way to the bottom
was i had to forgive myself because i
was the idiot that signed these notes i
was the idiot that built this house of
cards and then when they came falling
down
i want to blame everybody else and so i
spent a lot of time and effort
um just letting old dave off the hook
because i always thought of myself as a
pretty smart guy until i wasn't and it
shatters
it shatters everything right and so and
then the the
an extreme subset of that then that was
very easy to do once i did that
was let this jerk banker go who's dead
now by the way
right so you know i mean i don't know
why that matters in this conversation
but
you know but showed him right yeah i
showed him outlived him but yeah
but i did not kill him that's right
although i considered it at one point
yeah but the uh like we often have with
bankers but the
you know what i did do is make sure that
anybody having anything to do with this
bank never happened again because i talk
about it all times anyway so
the uh uh but the point being that that
once i got rid of me
off the list letting him go was easy
right and that can be writing them a
letter their family that can be
just saying i'm done with it i'm putting
it down having a small size i don't
think you have any conversation with a
guy about it i think he's inside your
heart
yeah i never called that guy and said
anything to him i just let him go in my
mind
set it down yeah he's out
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host best-selling author as we talk
to you about
all things business this hour it's an
entree leadership
theme hour what are your questions about
running and operating your business
you jump in and we'll help you with that
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five lauren's in
san francisco
hey lauren how are you i am doing just
great how are you dave and dr d better
than we deserve what's up in your world
man okay so i'm in san francisco
and i graduated debt-free with my
business degree at
22 years old wow i then went on to
get my mba at 24 years old
and i currently have about 55 000 saved
in my
investments good for you thank you
yeah so in 2018 i attended financial
peace university which just changed
everything and then again i attended the
smart conference
in 2019 in sacramento so i just
really value what you guys have to say
thank you you're very kind
yeah so um when i graduated with my
mba this was in 2020 during
covid um i was able to land my
dream job working at a startup company
out here
and i work like uh you know i i work a
lot
of hours but i make 75 000
plus bonuses so
sorry i'm really nervous that's okay
um so my question is
how do i deal with not having the same
aspirations and life goals as my friends
right now
because a lot of them i just feel like i
don't relate to them anymore
um you know a lot of them like they want
to get married and have kids
but i don't see that for myself for like
five more years okay yeah and you're how
old today
i am also sorry something really big
that i forgot to include
um i also during covet i started in llc
and during my free time that's where all
of my time goes
so when i'm not working at the startup
it all goes to the llc
and i'm going to be opening that up next
month so you're very goal-oriented
very ambitious and you are a
high-achieving
young lady what is your age today
25 okay
and so distill down for me what you're
asking
what how to how to deal with her friends
who have different aspirations
yeah okay so i just feel like i'm
starting to grow apart from a lot of my
friends
there you go you know i had a great time
with in college
i feel like we were just you know vibing
at that time
but as i continued to go down the
direction that i wanted to go
down which was you know continue to get
my mba
and then i landed my dream job and then
i was able to start my llc
and it's just they're starting to not
understand like where i'm coming from
like why i don't want to go out to the
bars on the weekend
and why i don't want to just throw all
my money
to things like coachella and things like
that
yeah so this this feels very
very lauren specific and i want to back
out and let you know this is a common
heartbreaking yet rhythmic season that
many
23 24 25 26 year olds experience and it
will happen again in your 30s and it'll
happen in your 40s
man you made some life-altering
friendships in college
you made some life-altering friendships
in high school and suddenly those
start to drift off and you become
hyper goal oriented i would guess that
one of those friends is going to call
another show somewhere and say we had a
friend who was so great and now she just
wants to work on her business and we
miss her
right so it's honoring what was
and not trying to continue to drag your
past into
your future it's knowing that here's
where we are
i still love them we had great times
and i have to be intentional about
making new friendships moving forward
and it doesn't need to be over
existential right
it's not a crisis you're not bad they're
not bad it just
is and it stinks and it happens
and what you have to be intentional
about is making sure you surround
yourself with other people
and you have to be intentional about
making new friends who have similar
interests or goal orient or
as goal-oriented as you or or fill in
the blank fill in the blank
but just locking yourself away for the
next five to seven years trying to work
on a business is going to leave you
lonely and ultimately
burned completely out right right
okay so i guess my follow-up question to
that um
so it feels a little bit lonely at times
and i don't really mind it because
i am following my passions i am so
so happy with my day job that i have
right now
and then all my time that i you know
that goes into it afterwards to my side
business it's just
i love it like i absolutely love it but
um i'm having a hard time finding
like-minded individuals and that kind of
again goes into the friend part of it
like
how do i find a mentor someone who i can
ask
you you don't need a mentor oh so
relationships are air
you have to have them as much as you
need air to breathe
are you involved in a good church
uh-huh okay uh start poking around there
listen
here's the thing guess what other young
women that are sitting
exactly where you are sitting are asking
exactly the same question as soon as you
find them they will be instantaneous
connections
and you'll be able to lock arms that way
and so
um yeah you just uh and for that matter
young men
uh it doesn't have to be i tell people
to go first and be awkward
yeah there's not another there's not
another way around it you reach out and
say hey i'm having four people over to
the house
i'd like it to be you that are there but
but those are people that meet
um specific things these are not bar
flies
these are people that are is that even a
thing do you say that anymore but anyway
but these are not people who hang out in
bars these are people that hang out in
business
and i want to put some people in my life
that are doing things like i'm doing and
i'm trying to get a group together it
may just be a supper club you may not
want to come but i'm going to ask you
anyway
and what is the worst possible thing
they can do is say no
and here's the thing once you find one
or two then they know one or two then
they know one or two and you'll be
shocked and amazed about what you put
around you and you're being very smart
because here's the deal lauren
100 of the people in the world become
who they hang around with
you become who you hang around with you
speak like them
you read the same books you see the same
movies
you binge watch the same crap on netflix
you you know you believe the same
theology you tend to vote the same way
you become who you hang around with now
i'm not talking about who you're
affiliated with who you know who even
that you like or admire i'm talking
about who your crew is
your closest five that you do life with
you're gonna be so much like them so you
better select them
carefully all right and when one of them
rolls out
right this will happen again when your
friends start having kids and you'll
realize one of them's a cub scout dad
and one of them is a
little league mom and it's you mourn it
again
and they're not bad they're not evil you
mourn it and then you
have different seasons of your life you
go back in every relationship whether
it's friendships marriage
they all start and end with risk and for
you business people out there this is
absolutely vital
you have to have people dave you have to
i mean you guys that are running
if you're running a business that has 15
team members
and you're you're only hanging out with
people who work a job
this is a mistake you need to be hanging
out with people that have businesses
that run
20 and 25 team members or 50 team
members because you're going to become
who you hang around with
that your thought patterns your speech
patterns your
sleep patterns everything you cannot
keep
the studies have actually shown that
your income over the next 10 years will
be
within 15 percent of the average of your
10 closest friends
and some of you are going i'm broke well
that means you mean you need some new
friends
i didn't know about that research so
while we're here hey dave you want to
come over tonight
let's go hang out no john i don't want
to bring my average down
oh you walked into it you walked in
your hand i gave that one to you man you
can only do that with your good friends
that's good no you got to have friends
you got to have friends you gotta have
friends
hey and friendships go through seasons
mourn them they're not bad don't go to
war with them but you have to be
intentional about
risking and finding new friends the
number of people my age is 60 years old
that still hang out with all the people
that hung out with high school
is exactly zero except uncle richard
uncle rico that's right
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's an entree leadership theme hour i'm
dave ramsey your host
if you're a business owner nothing about
this past year has been predictable or
easy
most of us are running harder and faster
than we did even before the pandemic and
that leads to one thing
burn up burnout fried if you're on the
brink of exhaustion running on fumes
lacking passion for your business you're
not alone
the good news is you don't have to live
this way this wednesday at 11
30 a.m central our own dr john deloney
sitting here to my right will be hosting
a free
webinar called overcoming business owner
burnout free on this webinar you'll
learn how to overcome exhaustion
reconnect with your mission and avoid
isolation
as a leader don't wait for a crisis to
take
down your business register for this
webinar today
text the phrase live webinar
to 33 444.
that's live webinar no spaces
2 33 4 44.
it's a free webinar this coming
wednesday
11 30 a.m central overcoming business
owner burnout with dr john
deloney you know john that's going to
be a drink of cool water for some folks
that are in the desert
yeah i think they but he did what they
had to do to survive
and it kind of barbelled after 2020
right everybody either
is looking at record profits but
suddenly they got more employees their
business is not what they knew it to be
or man they owned a dance studio or a
karate studio
and overnight it just went away and
everybody's
launched out of that and they looked up
eight months later man they don't know
their kids their spouse they
thought they could just treat yourself
and it'd be all okay man people are
really struggling i'll speak for myself
and say we had record profits
more than we had anticipated and
certainly more than we anticipated in
the middle of the pandemic because it
scared the
bejesus out of everybody me included in
terms of what it would do to the
business what would it do to the
thousand people that i'm responsible for
paying their
payroll and i'm responsible for their
kids eating as a result
and the stress of that but now we're the
other side of it and we've got these
unbelievable profits
but here's what here and i probably
don't need to do my counseling on the
air come on
but i think it's representative i really
do
uh i'm looking over my shoulder
[Music]
like is there another thing coming what
other stupid butt stuff is the
government gonna pull
what other stupid butt stuff is somebody
gonna blow the mathematics up and make
everybody
completely irrational when is i mean
because if they can do that crap once i
mean it
it it's i don't i don't feel as stable
even though i'm in great shape
financially i mean there's no question i
mean i could survive i can weather but
in terms of
being able to project into the future in
this
crazy butt environment that we're in
it's never going to be quite the same i
got this scar
now yeah is that is that wrong the word
we use is trauma no
there it is right there it is that's it
and so now your brain
is activated it's going to scan the
environment until you say hey
i'm okay we're okay somebody says covet
spike i just go into like
yesterday that's right just like you and
i talked about once i thought i'm scared
about coco but i'm scared about while
these crazy people are gonna do a round
coat
right you and i talked about it once um
i don't know if we're on the show or not
but i talked about you were in a car
wreck once somebody rear ended the yeah
just the crap out of you yeah
and now that when you go into that
middle lane to take a turn
you just feel yourself grabbing that
wheel a little bit tired that was years
ago right
yeah and so there's got to be a sense of
intentionality
um around
we're here now yeah sometimes it just
says it helps just say it out loud just
go you know that that's what that is why
i keep looking on my shoulder yeah we're
here we're here now
and so is something else going to come
yep yeah it is
probably not as bad as all that almost
never all that lizard brain stuff
is telling me yeah but it might be right
it might be we'll deal with it then
jonathan's in tri-cities jonathan what's
up in your world
hey it's a great honor to speak to you
guys um you guys have been a huge
influence in my
life the entree leadership has shaped
how we run our business
and uh so i appreciate all you guys do
cool yeah we have
we have a family-owned business here and
uh my two brothers and a partner so
things are going good we're been
successful growing fast
my struggle or question is today is kind
of as i bring
my brothers slash business partners into
this
you know to get them to buy more into
the
you know the business side of things or
working
in the business not just on the business
you know so we do really good at getting
our projects done and doing that
and leading people but sometimes the
business side of it
i feel like all alone at times you know
so what do you mean by the what is it
what is it you want them to do they're
not doing i'm confused
i guess probably just um you know
looking for you know their
advice counsel uh opinions on certain
things you know sometimes i think they
just leave a lot of it
up to me and so sometimes when i look
for answers so they're like they're like
doing their day job
running doing the thing that there is
their portion to do
producing the widget but then they're
not thinking about the overall thing
yeah unless i put it in front of them
and then sometimes even that i don't get
much feedback so
all right so dave what do you think
about that
um think i think you have a roles
clarity issue
okay there's two roles that you and your
brothers play
the same here at ramsey for me or rachel
okay rachel is an owner
of this business rachel cruz she's my
daughter
she's also a ramsey personality when she
is a ramsey personality she is getting
paid on the exact
same schedule that john deloney gets
percentage of speaking a percentage of a
book sale
or whatever so she's getting paid ramsey
personality money
if she does that job and that's all she
does that's all she's going to get paid
for doing that job as an owner
she gets paid a percentage of the
profits
and that's because she's an owner not
because she did something
those two things are separate and so you
need to say
you know in order to get in your case in
order to get owner pay
not just pay for doing your widget job
uh
you have to do owner work
because what you're talking about is
they're doing their you know
let's just make up something okay you're
you're a car mechanic you don't know
i don't know what you own i don't want
to put i don't want to put it out but
you know so
so they work on the cars all day and
they get paid for working on the cars
but when it comes to uh figuring out how
much rent we should
char uh pay what kind of building we
should rent or what kind of advertising
campaign we should do or
who we should hire to do our taxes they
all they want to do is work on cars
and so the deal is if you want to get
paid owner's share
you also have to be involved in the
owner the work of being the owner
and they don't get that part they think
if they just do their day job
that they're doing what they're supposed
to be doing it's okay to do either one
but you don't get owner pay unless
you're doing owner work
you only get mechanic pay for being a
mechanic
personality pay for being a personality
so did y'all start this thing together
or did you start it and then they're
coming in to help
no we're second generation so we kind of
took over from my
dad and uh and so that was about six
years ago so it was pretty small at that
time so
we've grown a lot how many team members
total we have a 30.
okay all right so this is going to be a
hard conversation how old are how old
are your brothers
40 and 37. okay
i i think you guys just sit down um
maybe even with the wives
and just and you start talking about it
because here's what i hear
and i think it needs to be corrected one
way or the other
i hear that you're the only person
running this business
yeah it feels like that at times well
that's what you feel that's what you've
conveyed
okay so you're the only one functioning
as an owner the other guys are
functioning in their
job inside the business and that's okay
you're my brother i love you if you want
to have a job here
i will pay you for doing a job but
owners
participate in owner work
that's a different task a different
job description than
you know okay let's say you're a
mechanic and you don't ever pay the rent
you don't ever get the taxes done and
you own the business
then you've not done owner's work and
you're gonna go out of business right
so i think you just sit down with all of
them and go guys it's okay with me
either way
but something's going to give because
i'm not going to be the only grown-up
but i think before that he's going to
articulate with those
owner responsibilities yeah you got to
write them down what does this involve
what is involved to own and operate a
business
the owner makes different level
decisions than the people who work in
the business
and if you just want to work in the
business you can be my brother and be a
mechanic and i'll put you on mechanic
pay
that's fine and i love you that's fine
nothing wrong with that but let's
clarify
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 4 23 above
all else guard your heart for everything
you do flows from it
peter marshall says may we think of
freedom not as the right to do as we
please
but as the opportunity to do what is
right
peter marshall's worth reading i was
going to say that's a great quote he's
worth reading
beautiful beautiful history there very
interesting guy
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is an entree leadership theme hour
we're talking business and leadership
don's in seattle
hey don how are you better than i
deserve dave how are you
better than we deserve how can we help
ah well
so i am very new to being a business
owner i'm oh
six or seven months in i have an
insurance agency and i have
one employee and i am struggling
with knowing when to be
compassionate and when to be firm when
it comes to
my employees viewpoints slash behaviors
and and then the other thing is they're
a point where
the drama they bring outweighs
the profit they produce i think you're
already there
i could be wrong but i can smell this oh
oh it's so painful though you have one
employee
yes sir are they killing it financially
and driving you crazy
the first month um yes the second month
not so much we are now going into month
three
of it and i've been i've had my agency
open for
um six months now
okay and the employee is supposed to be
doing what selling
insurance yes um selling insurance
through you know internet leads and how
old is this person
27. oh 27 year olds know everything
yeah so um when i was in your seat
i love your question because it shows a
big heart
and also a strong backbone both
the way you phrased it and you're trying
you you know you have the power
to just move this person on and yet
you want to do what's right by them and
be wise and learn how to lead
and these are all the way you phrase the
question was very strong very powerful
so um when i was in your seat i
uh with the first several team members
particularly in the south this is a
particular southern disease it
but it's everywhere but it's really bad
in the south we have this thing where
in the name of being nice we will
tolerate crap for
years and i was trying to be nice to
people
and what i figured out was i was getting
progressively frustrated
all the way into anger and i if i didn't
watch it was gonna just boil over
suddenly rather than me controlling the
environment
and so that's when i coined the phrase
for myself
to be unclear is to be unkind
because if you don't bring if you don't
let people in on what's going on inside
your head
then how can you expect them to have a
chance to adjust it's all in your head
and in the name of being nice you're not
telling them the truth
about what's driving you bananas now you
don't have to be blunt or angry or
rude to them but you owe them a
difficult conversation john
which often means you owe yourself a
difficult conversation of why is this
driving me crazy what are the actual
like so i i'm interested what are the
viewpoints that
your teammate uh is talking about that's
driving you bananas
well i i'm i'm 48 myself and i see the
world
through the eyes of a 48 year old and
they were 27 and i try to remember
what it was like when i was 27
and they are more mature than i was
at that age and i've also seen the
growth
that they've had since i met them six
months ago
give me an example um what are you
talking about like is it politics or is
it
is it religion like what is what is it
well
some of it's politics religion really
isn't it it's just
more of like behavioral viewpoints how
i see the world um for instance
i am not a victim i create my own
destiny
and i'm going to do it so let me help
you with this that's not an age thing
that's a world viewpoint thing i got a
building full of 27 year olds
that are not victims and they believe
they create the world the other ones i
don't hire them
because i don't want to work with
victims or people that think that
everybody's a victim
and the systemic man is out to get them
i got
i got crap to do and those people don't
do anything they whine
and i don't have time for them i love
the millennial generation
because there are only two kinds awesome
and sucks
and i hire the awesome ones i got a we
got a bunch of them yeah we have some
unbelievable young people in this
building and none of them
are playing the victim fiddle none of
them are thinking that society's out to
get them none of them think
that socialism is better than capitalism
and so i think you've got a bad hire
well that is the decision i've been
struggling with yeah you you you hired a
cat
and you're trying to train it to be a
dog have you sat down and said here are
the four things that need to change
i have not okay um this person has a
value system that does not align with
the owner of the company
if you your value systems have to be
aligned for you to have unity
you don't have to be in complete
agreement john and i have some fun
disagreements we argue
and fuss and fight and he thinks i'm
sometimes crazy and sometimes i think
he's way overeducated i mean we have
some great
discussions we love each other and trust
each other but overall our values
underneath all of those arguments are
the exact same
or very very close to the same and that
enables us to have these discussions
and disagreements that's where the
values have to line up the beliefs can
be all over the place that's why you
read new books to change your beliefs to
learn new things
but your values have he's reading a book
right now that's bizarre that i
recommended to him and i just finished
one that's bizarre that he recommended
to me yeah
and that's what friends do and i'm
hoping to change my beliefs on something
right but my values are the same
our values are very very simple and we
actually both came to the same
conclusions
about these books the good parts and the
bad parts that where the author was off
and on
and that kind of thing so i i i think
you're probably going to part ways but
you can try so have a clear conversation
and say
here this is what's driving me crazy and
honestly
i don't think that listen i don't know
how you're going to produce in a
capitalistic straight commission
environment selling insurance when you
think you're a victim or you think other
people are victims they're not victims
we need now is there situations where
people are oppressed you bet
are there situations where people don't
have the same starting line
absolutely are there all kinds of isms
out there that are real
abso dadgum lulu there's isms everywhere
there's jerks and ignorant people around
every corner
does that mean you can't win absolutely
not right
you can still win and so if you sit down
and have that hard conversation and say
here's who we're going to be moving
forward
and i'm not we're not going to do it
otherwise and i love you and then your
employees got a decision to make yeah
and it's okay
i'll still love you if you don't work
here yeah that's something you do great
dave
just said all the time i love you you
know you cannot work here and still go
to heaven yeah
it you know it's not required yeah it's
you can work a lot of places and still
go to heaven
you'll not it's not a call you'll see
some kind of it is you'll see
i'm just kidding not funny you'll
you'll see somebody in the grocery store
that used to work here and you'll still
give them a hug right yeah absolutely
yeah in a dead run yeah you know i mean
really yeah
because i just there's so many people i
mean
is we got a thousand here and in 30
years there's a thousand about that
don't work here right
you know and uh my wife and i joke about
we would never work with each other
right like in a business
that doesn't mean we don't love it yeah
it just does it means
there's too much going on and here's the
thing you everything moves at the speed
of trust and when you can't trust
someone's foundational underpinnings
that means you don't know what they're
going to do right you don't have a
predictable environment and business is
all about creating is
a predictable environment and that's
with your team members team members like
the predictable environment because the
leader is steady and you know i don't
always agree with him but i know exactly
what he's going to do
i don't always agree with her but i know
exactly how they think about this
they love that that's called integrity
and i also want
when i was a leader i always wanted to
surround myself with people who saw the
world differently to me that's the same
values
but i don't want someone to say oh you
vote that way or you think this so
you're out of here
go back to the what are your values be
clear you can spell trump so i can't
associate
with you whatever it is yeah man
surround yourself by people who think
differently but who have
the same values that's it yeah i don't
think this one's going to make it but
you can give it a run yeah but it's
going to be good for you in the process
clear conversations check out the entree
leadership website there's some good
stuff on there about it the podcast is
really good on it
that puts us hour in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ kelly associate producer
for the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
you